- Eat it!
- Stop! No! (laughs)
- Eat it! Or I'll cut your face!
(upbeat music)
- Today we're trying
weird kitchen gadgets.
- It's the stuff that you
see in Bed Bath and Beyond
that you don't need,
and you're like, of course
I need a melon baller.
- Can there be a fidget
spinner or something
coming out of us?
(upbeat music)
- So we're gonna crack the egg,
and we're gonna get
the yolk out with this.
- You could just do this
with an empty water bottle.
- This is not how you use it,
I can tell you right now.
- This is the guy who does Worth It.
- Oh yeah, look at that
- There ya go.
- egg crackin'.
- Oh sorry, that was beautiful.
- So you just go, dip it in.
- (laughs) No!
- Well now it's stuck. (laughs)
- You squeeze it, like full
fist it, and then go in.
- I gotta fist it?
- (laughs) Yeah, fist it.
- Honestly, a water bottle
works better than this.
(upbeat music)
- So we have to use this, vagina.
- So you hold it up like this,
and then you just push, you just (laughs)
- (grunts) Okay, there we go. Oh.
- Mine's supposed to be more ripe.
- Right, it's scary!
- I don't think that's how
you're supposed to do it.
(grunts)
- I actually regret doing that.
Do you have another mango?
- [Voiceover] No!
- Honestly, I could just use a knife.
(upbeat music)
- So we have a rabbit, and
- A star
- A car and a bear
- Oh my god, wait, this
is a hard boiled egg.
- We're gonna make it
look like this bunny?
- Does it break?
- It becomes an egg bear, and it's cute.
How does this work?
- Was that supposed to be a pun?
- No.
- (laughs) What?
- These eggs aren't big enough.
- Here, wait, let's do both eggs.
- No, my egg!
- What if we did this?
(laughs) Nothing.
- No.
- Oh, kind of!
(upbeat music)
(slicing)
- In case you don't know what that's for.
(laughter)
- That's where you went to college.
- Go Pizza!
- Oh wait, oh and then
I cut again here, oh
♫ Hallelujah, Pizza Pizza
- You're cutting at a
very interesting angle
that you've chosen to go in at.
(laughs)
- Here you go.
Boom!
This is pretty cool,
although fairly useless.
- Things that only have
one very particular use
really confuse me.
Like, how often are you cutting mangoes?
- These products, in
theory, are a great idea.
And some of them are great.
And then others, I'm just like, but why?
- This is the goddamn Shark Tank people
trying to come for our money,
like, I can do this on my own.
(upbeat jazz music)